[Musique]
on peut pas ne rien faire
s'agissant de la question des retraites
mais on peut pas non plus faire
n'importe quoi et on peut pas le faire
n'importe comment fait deux ans que le
gouvernement travaille cette réforme est
ce qui est incroyable c'est qu' il soit
parvenu à passer autant de temps à
discuter a essayé de négocier avec les
syndicats sans qu'il en ressorte rien du
tout et commerçants les artisans en ont
ras-le-bol ils ont vécu à aller gilet
jaune aujourd'hui les grèves alors que
le mois de décembre c'est un moment
important pour les commerçants c'est 30%
de leur chiffre d'affaires
un moment oui à la grève liberté de la
grève mais également la liberté de
pouvoir travailler de pouvoir circuler
que là pourquoi les syndicats se rebelle
parce qu'ils ont bien conscience qu'on
les prend pour des imbéciles
le gouvernement les prend pour des
imbéciles et donc aujourd'hui 10 bat non
stop
vous n'avez pas tenu vos engagements
vous ne tenez pas votre parole eh bien
on va continuer et qui est-ce qui
trinquent
ce sont les français et beaucoup
d'angoissé beaucoup de stress est rempli
de flou d'ambiguïté de contradictions et
de paradoxes à telle enseigne que plus
personne n'y comprend rien en instaurant
ce système l'âge pivot à 64 ans tout en
expliquant et en martelant comme il l'a
fait aujourd'hui dans ses annonces que
l'âge légal de départ était à 62 ans ils
trompent les français
qu'est ce que nous proposons
concrètement d'abord de dire la vérité
aux français oui nous devons travailler
davantage
un an de travail supplémentaires ces 16
milliards d'euros en plus pour financer
les retraites parce que nous proposons
cette réforme courageuse nous pourrons
entamer une réforme juste cette retraite
par points sans mesures d'âge ne peut en
aucun cas assurer la pérennité des
retraites des français sans compromettre
le niveau des pensions le gouvernement
ait fait un truc pas clair l'âge pivot
c'est une sorte de danse du ventre
de la ville ou à la retraite ils n'ont
pas assumé ils n'ont pas assumé ce une
mesure hypocrite et extraordinairement
type ok c'est pourtant ce que vous dites
aux gens vous avez le droit de partir à
soixante deux ans parce que le
gouvernement a pas le courage de reculer
l'âge mais vous allez partir avec une
petite retraite avec une super décote
c'est donc une mesure c'est donc une
mesure de réduction des pensions faut
bien que les français comprennent nous
avons un monsieur macron la double peine
nous n'avons pas de réformes et nous
avons la grève et les blocages avec les
républicains vous pouvez avoir une
réforme courageuse et juste parce que
l'idéal que porte et qu'attendent les
français c'est la justice sociale
[Musique]